we all didn't Bob but he won't admit it
what 10 years old
[Laughter]
maybe I am we met long before yeah yeah
we met let me forget it 14th Street on
14th Street he and I we shared some
friends together and while I was walking
we're walking toward I think it was
First Avenue or something and I saw Bob
coming the other way and he happened to
know the people I was with them they
introduced us Bob is born in Manhattan
as I am but I was born in on 86th Street
and you were born downtown the village
in the village and I found that at that
that time the that was shortly after
there was this real surge in Greenwich
Village of all the cafes and coffee
houses that did plays and poetry
readings and stuff and the village was
jazz we could have I mean that would go
that I went to hear those readings
I didn't read there but I know they they
were pretty pretty often and I did plays
there did you ever do play down there
once
well it's called best Bastiano cellar
was there and what are you right on
Waverly Place I didn't want a cappuccino
cappuccino in Phase two that's placed at
Woody Allen used
he would do the bitter end never the
bitter yeah yeah a lot of that stuff of
the cafes were great because when you
would you would do sixteen performances
a week of a play and they have to each
performance we passed the hand around
that many perform
so yes Jesus Wow how long was the play
what they usually short short unless
you're one act plays and then we pass
that around that's how we ate that's
great I really missed
okay I okay but for me they would
glorious I had a great time we've talked
about this a lot yeah I see we almost
did Glengarry Glen Ross together he was
gonna play the Levine mo and we were
really into it other things 1902 we're
gonna do care
I told who's gonna direct the the Glen
Garry was there a director that we had
well I don't remember that
don't know it was you and I look at it
do it we had no director we didn't have
Jimmy Foley's finally didn't do it it
was great but we were very close to
doing it what else
Papa Greenwich Village that was yeah
there's another one going very close to
doing and I remember we talked about we
were on the street one night outside
cafe central serving in Newark and I
thought this is how I remember I could
be wrong we were talking about Scarface
and you considering who to do it what
director and I was saying should really
do it with Brian of the choices that you
had I thought don't I thought I and then
and I said if you don't do it I'm gonna
do it because I want you know wanted to
yeah you you they were gonna do Scarface
Marty and and Bart they had they didn't
do it yet they were playing like the
idea of feeling about it and then I know
I I was I I when I saw Scarface I I had
in California I said I said call Marty
Bregman was the producer and I said I
think this is a this guy Palmeiras in
this part was well I said I think it was
great and I said I was just like to do
him if I could and then and then he then
he then he said darling and then I said
he didn't know Scarface I said see the
film I think we we can do it I didn't
know that Marty and Bob were we're
interested in just talking I think was
all those you know was it what he got in
a man bring him and Labette you know it
was laments idea to do it on it was been
Marty and and the met Tim that quite
agree on where the thing should go and
how it should be done and then Frank
they they had a party and Brian came in
and and that that was the I think that
was the thing that took it off because
the way Brian saw it and all of a sort
and Marty saw it and I saw had this sort
of you know this this kind of thing that
was always pretty much more opposite of
each other in certain areas and that's
when Scarface came about it I I just
thought I think I just felt Brian would
be the best because he would be the
least conventional of the choices of the
others truth directors those own and I
had work turned out that it was her that
was very true yeah because he did have
his own way of doing it that buts made
it different you know and I really did
take that film and so did Bregman by the
way he thought he had that that feeling
about it to larger than life just that
little step up during the time of
Godfather the way I understand it
Francis wanted the hell and but every
actor was up for it I I kind of knowing
that he that I was that Francis wanted
him I I thought of the sunny part of
like that too and I even read forward
for Francis but but he also wanted Jimmy
Caan for that the way I understand yeah
but everybody was up for the part and
then Al had a thing in the gang that
couldn't shoot straight that he had to
lead when he left to do Godfather then
they pulled me into I read for the part
of it was a kid's salary part of it was
the kid who's the from Calabria comes
over the bike yes and I think gave me
that part and that's how I was in them
it was such a nice where all he played
it so beautifully it's a great point
artist I mean there's just so much I
just saw the I just saw a casino the
other you know
and beautiful me but I guess the
greatest probably no smaller the
greatest performances on film film
history is his Raging Bull beyond belief
pretty much everything Bob does pretty
much life everything I've seen 640 but
Godfather 1 he was unique and special
and I of course understood that Francis
why Francis wanted out you know it's as
an actor sometimes you what would upset
you is if you someone does apart that
you were up for and they use them for
the wrong reasons and the person isn't
really as good you want them to be good
and so then you're happy okay well they
somebody who's good a great entity said
what what that's fine it's when they are
not good you say it's a disappointment
even weather that I couldn't have done
it system it's a disappointment that
they didn't direct it and have the
ability to get a great performance or
get an actor who would be up to what
that care that part needed I remember
once I was in a casting session and and
I'm sure this was China
I never even confirmed what Francis but
I know he was talking to I don't know
maybe it was Bob Evans or somebody and
they would say he was talking about
certain actors and I won't even say -
they were over and they were like so
wrong for the part like he said but I
know so no he's great and they've just
been in a hit movie at that time so it's
classic if I told you the names it's a
guy but I remember Francis being very
nice and diplomatic with
the powers that be that you know well no
they can't not really in this Anatomy
this justice Francis was kind of very
open in front of you I was just an act
of reading for it so that's you know
that's the absurd part of it would
they'll push somebody who's totally
wrong for it and I'm sure Francis was
under a lot of pressure for them to go
against whatever he would want to do
just for because it's the flavor of the
month of the year and he stuck without
you know I thought we would get together
and and rehearse and Bob said no I don't
think it's a good idea and he was he was
right because they never saw each other
before and it was a simple scene and so
when we came to shoot that was the time
we met up and acted together for the
first time you're looking to become a
phonologists you're looking to go back
you know I chased down some crews guys
just looking a [ __ ] up get busted back
at you
we must have worked some [ __ ] crews
I've worked all kinds
you see me doing thrill-seeker liquor
store holdups were born to lose tattoo
on my chest no I do not right
I am never going back then don't take
down scores I do what I do best
that takes course you do what you do
best trying to stop guys like me I love
that scene you know and I was looking
forward to us doing it eventually I
always loved the way it was written the
whole thing was great for us and the two
cameras which is always nice it was good
it's so great to be working with them
actually working with them now like most
films you know they go through a lot of
a lot of levels and this started years
ago I remember sitting with Marty and
Bob you know in a hotel in LA talking
about it
and that was like about five or six
years before before it happened yeah
when you and I we walked over her body
was in the hotel we had a meeting really
good and and and I kept thinking he was
gonna come about sooner or later it but
I knowing about this stuff because you
know you you you wouldn't you
experienced with it you know that it's
gonna it's gonna go to various
incarnations and it'll finally find its
way and it did finally who's always go
you know Marty was doing another project
I mean I had something out we are it's
something but he had he was the driving
force had to wait for him to be ready
being the director it takes more time
doing one movie and once once
when I was passing through London he was
doing what's the movie with a 3d that he
did with a Hugo yeah
and so we talked and he was just it was
there and I I said well I'm gonna I want
to get your permission and then I got
your permission and then Joe Pesci's
that may be from time to time we talked
about it because I'm very suspicious
about that and since it was so far off
we didn't have a date because everybody
wants to know when the date the start
they would be said Marty I'll Joe do you
guys mind if I say it or any of us can
say from time to time can I say that are
we able to say that everybody's
comfortable with that because in me it
would mean that times I've always
superstitious you say it and then it
doesn't happen that's happened to me but
I felt this one was one that we should
put it out there and even though things
were still loose about commitment to
time you know we had ups and downs of
how who's gonna finance it and then
finally Netflix came and made it easy
for all of us and it was a good thing
because I feel obviously because it
could do it we could do it and not be
anxious about the budget and the
technical stuff that had to be done
which Marty needed to have the ability
to do that with a bit of freedom so that
the
not to be too haggling about this and
that so it was a good good thing and
also I think the other thing was that
you you put together the reading put
together reading of them of the film and
we had about 50 people with every with
photographic and that Pesci and some of
the players yeah some of the actors you
and you had Manu and one body hurry I
would almost Bobby Cannavale II yeah he
was the father was there poor on them a
lot of people who like a lot of times I
do then because you know outs got me out
to it I said for example if we're
considering doing a part or something
say how about having a reading with the
director and not necessarily the actors
we're gonna be in it some will be in it
or maybe but it's just a loose thing and
everybody understands that yeah just sit
around have a reading to kind of lift it
off the page a little bit and that
reading could mean that you will commit
or not commit it or whatever but just a
way of another sort of way of inching
closer to the project so he started me
on that you get a sense of the project
I've taken something I'll see it because
I read I read aloud pretty woman you
know with the young Julia Roberts hmm
and would Garry Marshall got a group of
us together and I was I was actually
filming something five and I went and we
read it and you could tell I mean I
could tell after the reading of this is
gonna be a good this is gonna be a hit
picture he just knew and this girl was
phenomenally I mean I just saw him Gary
with when did you get this girl and
and so you really got a sense of it and
that was just proved you know that's
instinct was was correct so you do learn
a lot from it I didn't do the picture
did they offer to you yeah I offered it
to me I think one of the things that we
shared which was really helpful was we
we would talk to each other occasionally
about our lives because our lives have
changed you know pretty radically from
with all of a sudden being well-known
and stuff so we would share that with
each other and it was very comforting
and at certain times yeah and we get he
knows a lot about me out there and I
know a lot about him and so cuz were you
would think they you know and it was
really quite a few times Bob has helped
me out
you